the Joe Rogan experience when did you
start training what you just started I
started I've been doing it for about
yeah not even ten years nine years so I
actually started MMA training as just a
kid to keep fit while I was playing
rugby league so I was a you know that
was when I was 214 pounds so that's
something that uh obviously when we when
you when I'm fighting and you say 240
and it'll slow your language you guys
have that Australian language things
different more sense yeah 100 percent
you know five or six on a good day you
know Elena
give me a good stretch yet do some yoga
sessions I'm I'm eight five five foot
six but you know I mean it's just a yeah
aza you know a lot bigger and I wanted
to stay fit in between yeah in between
like sort of the season preseason so
that's why I went and started and just
loved it ever since so that was about
again 9 years ago so and hold you now 31
Christ you're 31 that head so you were
you know early early 20s and no martial
arts training at all before that um I
wrestled so I wrestled before even done
rugby leg arrested for about probably a
year I can't even remember was you know
honestly I was I done it for about a
year and you know I've done pretty good
it was something that I was actually
pretty good at but you know I wanted to
play football with my mates and I've got
over wearing the tights you know
wrestling and stuff like that so you
know it was just something that yeah I
end up just playing football with a mate
so I sort of gave it up and I was
actually pretty good at it so we wonder
when the Nationals look you know
obviously it's the wrestling is not as
big in Australia as it is over here but
you know it's the one lakh strain
championship twice and stuff like that
but then I just I just gave it up and
stand yeah so that's crazy so you won
the Australian national twice yes yeah
so that was a yeah they have maybe year
you don't even training for a year you
don't sit for yeah honestly I remember
we used to have a gamed night we call
those at a PC why say police boys club
it's just a local club usually they'll
have like games nights and they'd had
wrestling there and I just went there
time and the you know the trainer was
just like oh you should come and do
training because I was doing alright so
I just started doing it and then I was
actually pretty good again I was always
like I literally you know come out the
the mother's room like this you know
what I mean so I'll be nice decently
I've been this big or you know this hard
and he looked this old look for you know
since I was like 12 so I was always I
was always versum guys to Isis awesome
me and you know animate cells you know
all that much older as well and I used
to do well so that's why a lot of people
you know for those mad you know when I
gave that up because I was doing so good
and then the same was a rugby league
when I played rugby lay given people
thought I was mad giving that up as well
because of something I was pretty good
at as well so what made you decide to
make a switch to MMA professionally um
just my last year of football rugby
league we you know we won that calm you
know I got player of the match I scored
a 40 meter try so you can imagine that
guy running 40 meters yeah so it was
just a you know was just yeah good year
to finish on you know I mean I had a
couple of fights as well that year so I
was training it MMA and having a couple
of fights while I was playing for rugby
league oh really
yeah that was during the season yeah
yeah in the season you're having fights
yes you'd have a game and then you know
a fight yeah yeah yeah so was that
pretty full-on and still working still
concreting yes yes Christ it was pretty
pretty full-on so a lot a lot happening
you know and I guess that's probably
where I get some of my fitness today as
well you know I mean I've just always
been a bit of a gamer and you know just
it's just something I've always done but
maybe from back in them days as well
well I would imagine that just the sheer
tenacity and cardio that you would get
from rugby rugby is a tough [ __ ]
sport yeah I mean that's what I think
Americans should play
I really do I look at American football
Mike what's up with the shoulder pads
and you know honestly I think it's safer
I think rugby safer I don't think it's
safe it's obviously a very rough combat
sport a lot of mean it's kind of a
common it's kind of like a team combat
sport almost but you were at least not
under the illusion that you're protected
like American football players have been
for so long with the helmets and the
pads mm-hmm and that's what's causing a
lot of the brain trauma
yeah with him hard helmets a new you
mean
I knew each other you know yeah it's a
yeah I guess I know I can see what
you're saying there as well but you know
then again then you're looking at that
you know someone running that you know
no no helmet as well but I get what
you're saying I actually think you know
I think you're right I think you Denis
on there well I think they they've
considered this but people are so
accustomed to football helmets football
pads yeah so the idea is to just make
better helmets and better pads but
according to the guys who really study
traumatic brain injury that's not really
gonna help because it's the impact yeah
though the head the brain swashing
around inside your skull that is just so
the the amount of mass that you have
these guys colliding into each other
it's almost unavoidable yeah it's like
what actually when you talk in boxing
and that as well and a lot of people you
know obviously we go to smaller gloves
right but then the boxers they have more
padding but it's just so many more
strikes to the head day in day out and
they reckon that's actually you know it
can be actually worse for yeah I imagine
is and then also there's nothing else
you can you don't even allow to clinch I
mean if you clinch they separate you you
know whereas an MMA if you get rocked
you could at least protect yourself yeah
and if it goes to the ground you can
hang on you could try to submit someone
you can try to wrestle with them there's
not a lot of options in boxing you know
yeah definitely so what so you you did
well in rugby mhm and you had a couple
of fights while you're playing right
what was it was it just a one on one
aspect of it like what made you decide
to focus entirely on that I mean I've
always loved martial arts you always
loved it and I love the fact that you
know you're in there by yourself you
know I've always been a hard worker yeah
so you could play the best game of your
life and say rugby league and still lose
well you could do everything right you
know make thousands of meters whatever
someone else [ __ ] so well yeah again you
know I don't want to put it out yeah
well exactly right that's sort of even
even it could be vice-versa
I could play a bad game we could win but
I love you know the fact that I'm such a
hard worker and you know I'm always
putting the hours in the gym you know
I'm so dedicated this sport that's so if
I lose in that cage that's on me you
know what I mean and I love that I love
the fact that you know if I am
half-assing it you know in the gym
you're gonna see that comfort time and
I've got no one else to blame but myself
so
you know that's I've always loved that
and again I've just always loved
Marshall I think the boxing UFC even you
know before I even started a you know
training MMA I'll duck you know listen
to music and older you know just picture
myself winning the world title
oh yeah I've always loved your train I
wasn't even training you know it's just
something that I've always loved I
actually started watching it back when I
think because we we had a box you know
you get the the chips and you can watch
whatever channel you want and the
pay-per-view was I probably shouldn't
say that but anyway so pay-per-view was
on and I remember watching a chocolate
there oh no no sorry Tito Ortiz and Ken
Shamrock that was the first time their
first fight so that was the first time I
ever started watching like UFC and and
that's when I just absolutely started
loving it so I've always you know
watched it and loved it and you know
picture myself being in there and all
that and I wasn't even trying at the
time that's well Australians are tough
as [ __ ] it's like it's a tough [ __ ]
place
there's something there men you know
what I mean there's a lot of I mean sure
there's some [ __ ] over there too
they're men you know I mean like it's
like one of the ways that people look at
Australia it's like it makes sense yeah
great combat sport athletes would come
out of Australia in colony well now I
mean that's really what you guys do
exactly right you know especially a you
know as you're saying you know if you
see me being a being looking like this
since I you know since a young age okay
obviously you're gonna I'm not the type
to brag that you know get into fights
and all that sort of stuff but when I
was younger that that would happen and
so I've always been known to fight and
being able to fight type of thing I've
always that you're sort of defend myself
never been the one to start it but yeah
those times where I had to finish it but
you know so it's just always something
that I guess I've had enemy so I mean
Australia you guys have John Wayne par
just vanished
you guys have had some great combat
sports athletes cuz you know well that's
now it's you have say so big in in
Australia so we've always had as you're
saying very talented guys you know we've
got a lot of very good athletes over
there but that will always in your rugby
league's and AFL or whatever it is now
UFC and MMA is getting so big that your
wig in these athletes that know you know
trained MMA and you're only gonna see it
grow even more we're gonna get a lot a
lot more champions from out from our
[Applause]